друзям і вірти не
проводимо евакуацію можна на сало
прощаються зинке edit і ми запуску чому
ми 206 батальйон pride реально бро на
місце кіло за б скачуваної шкоди
процесу евакуації щось би врятував кричати на
суму евакуацію для дітей дружиною
нікого не сумнівайтеся в тому, що ви
українці нікого набиті сварога б ти його
і захищають цю основу
мало все добре не проживав все
добре до розлому
гараж на руку
сідайте випиті крім
ось вона теж працює
де
але
керувати подачі привіт сидить обидві руки
вбийся все буду добрим
балів а
ось така як на
битви півень рона все добре
привіє
спасибі
глава
руку
буваю
вибором банку довго
не підлягає
але думаю бійцю наводила не 40 англійська
а
ось за позовом виражена
поки те ж саме відбуватиметься
давайте руку до обрію дістатися треба
переживає всі добрі випиті збитки і
тримай аубакірова gift вбити
вісім набив sims ii буду добрим
пошук обидва рази
ви півень шкоди на переживаємо сьогодні
йде
я випробуваю той
віскі жорсткої батальйон територіальному
ворона містики у вакуумі людей замість
терпили
швидше швидше
чуєш фіджі
а
на
привіт дай
друзі з люди його кльово нізар мене
сьогодні
російські
[музика]
[сміх]
друзі uk скачати біласко хибкою в
можливо в дніпр і ліг а не через те
а у вас там лежить
ми
нарешті ж бугай все забрала вербень
[музика]
[сміх]
розібрав і іншому з Києва
підводячи його не сенпай кийком
та розведу ванку піднімаємо
це платить цій отруті проти мене на
вокзал
і нам і не чекаємо а
ці солі
[музика]
еллада смузі рукою лоно помахай рукою
все і при пожежі ми вам щасливою
дороги і ми ваша його вам вікна та спорту
power лінію швидше буду ваші льоду повз
ми рубатимемо і всім потрібні наші воїни
ми водойми територіальну оборону щоб
ви були російського міста з українською
землі ми всі йому кожному з українки кікі
прийдіть і вона
може вже будь-яким of many common це
вбитий ми начебто своїх
і слова і